hi i'm steve clemons and i have a
question will the ukraine war stem the
rising tide of authoritarianism and
reignite liberalism around the world
let's get to the bottom line
in many ways ukraine has become not only
a proxy fight between the east and the
west but a battle between ideologies on
one hand there's liberalism in the
enlightenment values and on the other
authoritarianism in ukraine's case the
question is do states have the right to
make their own choices and their own
friends what does it mean if states
don't have sovereignty and independence
in russia's case do its fears for its
national security justify the carnage
that we're looking at every day will it
do anything to prevent ukraine from
joining a western alliance that makes
russia feel threatened does might make
right so what will the global
consequences of this war now be will
authoritarianism everywhere begin to
falter and what happens on the other
hand if russia wins joining me today is
political philosopher francis fukuyama
whose book the end of history and the
last man came out in 1992 and argued
that western-style liberal democracy had
evolved over all other ideologies what
he didn't say is that other forces
wouldn't try and make a comeback now
he's coming out with a new book
liberalism and its discontents about the
challenges to liberal democracy how do
you see
uh russia ukraine in this moment
i think that there is a much larger
fight going on
uh i started going to ukraine regularly
back uh uh in 2013.
my center at stanford runs a number of
training programs for hopefully a new
generation of ukrainian leaders and we
did this because
all the way back then you know beginning
with russia's seizure of crimea uh and
the donbass
uh it seemed to to me that this was the
front line in a global struggle
between democracy and authoritarian
government
you know there's two separate issues you
talked about sovereignty and so there's
a general principle
that countries shouldn't be invaded by
their neighbors
that
might doesn't make right and that people
have a right to
uh they're living in their own countries
but there's also an issue about uh
liberal democracy
and you know to me the the second issue
is
maybe even more important
uh i think that
you know i i had this feeling i remember
when i was walking through the maidan
the central square and kiev
uh uh the last time i was there just
looking at the people walking around the
street it was like a normal western
european city people were free they
could
criticize the government they could
organize they could
really
vote for whoever they wanted and when
they voted for president zielenski they
picked a complete outsider to the kind
of corrupt establishment that had been
very dominant in the country and so
you know there's some pretty basic
values at stake when russia
decided that actually no ukraine is not
a sovereign nation it really
belongs to us
and i think what was driving that was
that issue of liberal democracy because
putin had asserted at several points
previously that slavic peoples that the
the what he calls the greater russian
people and that includes ukrainians
are really not suited for democracy that
they like a strong centralized uh
dictatorship
and the ukrainians were proving him
wrong uh if democracy could flourish in
ukraine it could flourish in his country
and that obviously represented a big
uh threat to his regime and so i think
those are the broader issues that are at
stake it's not just the question of
sovereignty it's also the question of
whether uh you can have a
a free society in a place like ukraine
and whether other free societies are
going to support it
a lot of people have thought that
while we were hand-ringing in the west
and talking about you know democracy's
tough days and do we have to fight and
struggle for democracy i don't think
anybody there thought the face of that
would be vladimir zelinski and the
ukrainian people that fighting for
democracy has become very very tangible
very bloody a very hard fight and i'd
love to know your thoughts because this
this was framed by karaganov and others
as a fight not over ukraine's
sovereignty but over the battle with
democracy
well i think that in a way um putin has
done all of us a favor by
reminding us what the stakes are in uh
you know the issue of democracy
i think that
you know europe uh by and large has been
very fortunate to have lived in relative
peace and prosperity i mean that
has been generally true in western
europe for 75 years since the end of the
first second world war
and in eastern europe since 1989 1991
you know those countries were liberated
from
uh communist dictatorship and you've had
a whole uh generation of people grow up
uh under a a democratic framework uh
that's connected to the global economy
that's produced prosperity uh and the
like and i think that
you know when you're living in that
condition you tend to take it for
granted you
think in the abstract yeah maybe we need
to fight for it but you don't actually
have to fight for it
and all of a sudden we've got a
situation in which people are
desperately fighting uh you know for
their way of life and i think it's a
very useful
and by the way i mean i i
this doesn't justify anything that's
happened
um
you know because the the suffering in
ukraine is just it's horrible and it's
very very unfair that
in a way they're bearing a burden on
behalf of all of us
um but that being said i do think that
you know it's reminded people in the
west that they can't take
uh liberal democracy for granted and
that it does require some struggle
you know there's a tendency i think in
the media right now
to try to distill this down almost uh to
the point of being a star wars script
you know they are darth vader in the
empire you know luke skywalker and the
jedis are on the white side but but
there are a lot of folks that don't see
it this way they see
america's invasion uh in response during
the iraq war as something where america
was perceived by many around the world
to have adopted a might makes right uh
mentality in some things they see the
united states as a nation that was kind
of gravity-less in a lot of the
decisions it made in the world and
didn't always see it as a benign
player in global affairs
are there moments of introspection we
have to have
uh on the united states side of what we
need to do to be greater supporters of
the kind of liberalism that we're all
talking about today
well first of all what you say is
correct i was just in the balkans and
there there's actually a fair amount of
support for putin
and a fair amount of cynicism about the
european union and about the west in
general because
you know a lot of those countries have
been trying to get into the eu and
they've been largely
blocked in that path
but
you know of course the introspection is
necessary and very important and i do
think that the mistakes that have been
made in american foreign policy like the
iraq war
uh have echoed you know through the
years in ways that were not anticipated
that have been very damaging
to america's image into the image of
democracy
you know democracy promotion in the eyes
of many is
synonymous with invasion and that's you
know that's a very bad situation
i just think the timing is important so
that introspection is uh
important but i don't think that that
should
get in the way of our doing whatever we
can to help protect ukraine because
that protection really needs to come now
and i think that um
you know having these self-doubts uh at
this particular moment is just not the
right timing for it uh hopefully
if this russian assault can be beaten
back then i think it'll be completely
appropriate to say well
we haven't created the kind of world
where
nobody uses military force you know
across borders in this particular
fashion i guess i've been asking you
know over your long career of looking at
russia of looking at the soviet union
what did we get wrong after 1989
that we need to
pay attention to
after this episode is over whatever you
predicted putin is going to have a bad
end and will will lose and won't survive
that loss what do we do at that moment
so that we don't repeat history again
yeah that's a really complicated
question i think there's an internal
russia dimension and a foreign policy
dimension
i think in terms of
what the advice we were giving russia as
they were trying to make a transition to
a market economy we made a lot of
mistakes that we haven't fully
owned up to i think that
we kind of assumed at that point that uh
you know this is sort of the neoliberal
wave that that had had gripped you know
a lot of economists at that time that
somehow uh free markets were the answer
to everything and that they would be
self-sustaining without
a political structure of a state that
could actually enforce property rights
and and the like
and i think we encouraged a uh
too rapid transition to a market economy
in a way that impoverished a lot of
russians
uh whether we could have
you know reversed that by
a marshall plan for russia i don't know
that's a complicated question but i do
think a lot of the economic advice that
we were giving at that time
was was really
wrong that the transition should have
been much more careful and much more
gradual the foreign policy argument is
one that's still echoing you know in
uh in in people like john mearsheimer
where
you know the argument was that we should
not have uh expanded nato
and that russia might have developed
into a kind of normal
you know maybe somewhat authoritarian
but but not a terribly ambitious country
uh if we had not pushed nato right up uh
to its borders including countries that
had been part of the former
ussr
that argument i i don't
you know it's a counter factual that
that nobody's ever going to be able to
prove i just don't believe that that's
the case because
uh i think that the eastern european
country first of all the expansion was
not driven by
uh you know by the west it wasn't driven
by washington it was driven by
countries that had a long historical
experience of living under
uh russian power uh and they understood
i think that
once the balance of forces changed and
russia was powerful again that they
would
revert to this long-term
historical pattern of trying to dominate
their neighbors and that they wanted
some
uh protection against that and i think
that you know if you look at putin's
narrative he
claims that his
the reason for his acting is a kind of
short-term threat posed by ukraine to
russia's security
but if you listen to the other stuff he
says about how
important it is to reverse the entire
democratization
of you know the the of eastern europe
that occurred after 1991
you see that the issue is this one of
democracy versus authoritarianism
and it really doesn't have to do with
ukraine it's really
trying to restore the former soviet
union uh in all of its glory and
reversing uh the the
the idea of a europe hole and free that
that we supported at the end of the cold
war
uh and i think that that would have
happened regardless of whether we had
expanded nato if we hadn't expanded nato
then poland and the baltic states would
be in exactly the same position that
ukraine is in today
so that's my
view i cannot prove that again because
it's a counter factual but i i believe
that that was not the fundamental
mistake that we made i'd be interested
in in your reflections not only on the
global
uh wave that has hit some of these
populist leaders but also the what's
been happening in the u.s political
system and and how you see the the the
winners are losers or the shaping of
voices from this point forward you know
in in in the u.s electorate
well i think the impact is going to be
uh
quite extensive um
you know it's interesting that all of
those populist leaders
beginning with donald trump as you
mentioned all liked
uh vladimir putin
and i think it
tells you it tells you something about
the nature of this new wave of populism
you know there's been this argument
where a lot of people have said well
populists are just doing things that are
popular but they're basically democratic
and they're representing a group of
people that feels neglected and despised
and looked down upon
there's a degree of truth to that but i
think the uh
the attraction to putin indicates that
there's something else that's much more
sinister
uh behind their agendas which is that
they actually don't like liberalism
meaning
not
the cultural liberalism that we've been
fighting about in this country but
liberalism in the sense of a
constitutional
order that produces a rule of law that
restricts the power of
executives and presidents
and prime ministers to just do whatever
they want they like the idea of a strong
leader
that can just cut through
you know all of the all of the
bureaucracy and and rules and just do
what the people want
and it's a very dangerous tendency and i
think that's one of the reasons they
like putin
the fact that so many of them
are on record um praising putin trying
to get photographed with him like marine
le pen uh
or failing to criticize him in any way
like former uh president trump
uh that's something that you know their
opponents can hang around their heads
the next time they're up for
uh an election
uh because i think that the
um you know the devastation and the
moral clarity that has been produced as
a result uh will reflect on them and
will reflect on the kind of moral people
that they are or in this case aren't
what sorts of pressures do you think
this moment puts on china i remember
reading a piece you wrote years ago
that as we had simultaneous wars going
on in afghanistan and iraq the united
states and the west
china was on a charm offensive around
the world and taking advantage of that
moment i see china right now of course
you know we also saw pictures of xi
jinping with vladimir putin recently but
in other ways if you were kind of look
at it analytically china's trying to
keep its powder dry in some ways i'd be
interested in what you think they're
getting out of this what impact you see
on china and the way it engages
with the equities it cares about in the
world
well there's two
separate questions with regard to china
that we need to think about so
the first is the more short-term one uh
do they actually answer putin's call for
assistance
and there there seems to be increasing
evidence that they've decided that they
made a wrong bet
and that they don't want to
you know
associate themselves with
a leader who has become a global pariah
they've got a lot of short-term economic
interest in not getting caught up in
secondary sanctions and the like i mean
it's not going to be possible to
sanction china the way russia has been
sanctioned but
it still will have a bad impact and i do
think that there's still this residual
desire
to be seen as a
you know a good player in global
politics and so
it looks like they're uh trying to back
away from you know what at the olympics
uh they had you know called uh
and whatever it was a forever friendship
uh the more um
crucial thing is a longer term issue
about taiwan
because
you know as many people have recognized
they want to take back taiwan they've
pretty much said that that could happen
peacefully or
there might be circumstances in which it
might have to happen militarily
i think that the
calculus that they're making on taiwan
is first of all obviously the military
dimensions of an attack
but you know more importantly what's the
response going to be what's the response
from the united states and what's the
response from the rest of the world
and i think that if i were a chinese
leader i would be very careful
uh you know the
russian military did not perform at
anything like the level that it was
expected to given all the money that had
been poured into
new weapons and
training
and i think
china will suffer from similar problems
uh but more importantly the kind of
resolve of the
democracies around the world to resist
that has been very surprising and i
think the chinese are probably taking
that into account as well
so i do think it may have you know some
deterrent effect can you finally just
give us a quick um glimpse of your new
book that's coming out
soon liberalism and its discontents you
know knowing a frank fukuyama book i
know that you probably are giving
counsel to those of us who believe in
the liberal order uh that we've not been
doing our job that we've been kind of
bored at the switch that there are a lot
of things that haven't been you know
held up and you kind of see that in the
way uh even the kind of boredom over the
uh uh you know the big summit for
democracy that joe biden had recently it
was kind of a yawn that came and went so
i'd love i'd love our audience to kind
of hear about the book if you give us a
quick moment on it
uh sure so
i think that um
for many people especially kind of gen z
uh people that have been born after the
cold war and have a very different
experience
liberalism seems like old hat you know
it seems like something that their
parents generation or maybe even their
grandparents generation believed in but
it's not appropriate
for the moment
you know that's for many progressives on
the left and i think for
people on the right they blame
liberalism for
all the terrible things that they see
affecting uh you know let's say american
national identity you know the attack on
religion and disrespect for uh kind of
ordinary americans who are patriotic and
hard-working and so forth
and there's been a lot of debate about
the rights and wrongs of all of these
different criticisms but
in the process you know it seems to me
that nobody's gotten up and said yeah
i'm you know i'm an old-fashioned
liberal and i'm proud of it and i think
that there's a lot of
intrinsic reasons why liberalism
is the best political system and that
none of these uh criticisms that have
been made ultimately are are decisive
so that's why i decided to write this
book i mean it deals with all the
criticisms and explains why i don't
think they're correct
but it's also an attempt to explain you
know why liberalism exists
why it's a good thing why you should be
very grateful for living in a liberal
society as opposed to either a kind of
nationalist or
you know a
more traditional kind of
uh
authoritarian country and why
you know some of the ideas on the left
for replacing liberalism with you know
some form of identity-based politics is
also not a good idea
uh so that's really the purpose in in in
writing this to say
you know say it now and say it loud i'm
a liberal and i'm proud.
let me ask you one last question
president zielenski is speaking to
parliaments all over the world they're
remarkable speeches to the canadian
parliament to the u.s congress now to
the european parliament and he's asking
for more he's asking for help he's
asking for uh military supplies uh
airplanes no-fly zones is america doing
enough from your perspective is joe
biden doing enough uh to give zelensky
what he needs
yeah the no-fly zone issue is a really
difficult one uh and one that
might be you know i have not been in
favor of that and that's something
that's upset a lot of my ukrainian
friends
i think that there's a kind of technical
issue that many people don't understand
which is that
if you were to
impose a no-fly zone over ukraine
you would have to attack russian targets
in russian territory
because a lot of the threats uh you know
the rockets that are raining down on
kharkiv and kiev and other ukrainian
cities are coming from russian territory
and you can't really protect ukraine
without actually
attacking russia and for nato to
start that kind of attack i think is a
very grave step
it may be necessary at some point but i
think that we haven't reached that
that moment yet
uh and so i think that
you know what we need to do is to
accelerate what we've been doing which
is to provide them with
you know the maximum amount of usable
ground-based air defense systems you
know like s-300s
that can be used in the short run to
protect
ukrainian cities
but to not go you know to the next stage
of escalation because i just think the
the
scenarios that could unfold from that
are really pretty uh numerous and pretty
scary well francis fukuyama author and
senior fellow at stanford university
thanks so much for being with us
thank you steve
so what's the bottom line sometimes
history goes to sleep francis fukuyama
wrote about the end of history 30 years
ago when the soviet union fell apart now
he says history is waking up we're being
reminded of what the stakes are if might
makes right becomes the rationale for
any country's behavior as america did in
the iraq war and banding about populist
slogans like america first which really
means an america that doesn't care about
the rest of the world populist leaders
don't like liberalism they don't like
the give and take of a democracy where
both political winners and losers
actually believe in the rights of each
other
but as graphic and disturbing as the
image of ukraine atrocities are maybe
fukuyama is right they are igniting the
spirit and the purpose of those who
believe in justice in liberalism
democracy and sovereignty history is
awake again and that's the bottom line
[Music]